The tax base is a community workshop. There's lots them all over the world
Nassim is probably one of the biggest if not the biggest in the UK
This we have a whole load of tools that people can use for their hobbies or even be even businesses
Is the sort of thing that you perhaps couldn't have to afford to have in your garage or don't have the space for that
But this is some week you can join and get access to those sort of facilities
We're totally run by members. We don't have any members of staff
so it's all run by volunteers and we rely on their membership fees for buying new tools and
equipment and stuff
We've run various workshops here or all sorts things up some summer craft related jewelry related but quite a lot of computer related
Workshops we've had raspy Pye workshops. I actually run the Arduino which are some long with another maxxbass member
There's a really good for people just sort of get over the initial hurdle of getting started with the Arduino
So, you know if you buy an Arduino board, it's often. There's the certain hurdle
You need to get over to get started. We come to one of our workshops
we've got a brain wall planned out where you
Don't have to have any previous knowledge of programming or electronics and we'll get you started
with that get started flashing the ideas most
electronics projects the software project so involve embedded
circuits start with and then we work through the various bits of programming circuits do to
controlling speed of the motor with something called pulse width modulation
People at the hack space have helped us out with videos
Our very first computer file video was a defender clone that Michael has made
The vending machine Rob miles is obviously an active member of the hack space and he's done a lot of videos here
James has done some things on the Arduino first Spencer has done some
Well, we've got about 640 numbers
I'm sure you got many more you could fill there as we go from one around
I think the building were in was actually an old lace
Building but it's now Lots little businesses in here lots of band practice rooms for the month with the noise as we go past certain
Areas, this is the main interest not in that space and we've got RFID cards for getting in so
After you come through the street door
Put your car in front of here
We've got Halloween and then the door is unlocked we can get in so welcome to not a compact space
That's all based on Arduino and behind the scenes. There's some
Code and obviously MySQL database with all the all the details of the RFID cards
We have a quite active software team Lee so behind the scenes that have run writing one of our membership system
And we're currently running a HS h ms. One system. Hex based management system one
They're working on version two at the moment rewriting at all in
PHP there laravel framework. This is what we call our comfy area over this side
We've got a museum of outdated technology. So we've got a Commodore pet up there
I think that's been in the background in your video
It probably has it probably has we've got quite a few members who are interesting retrocomputing
So you're probably a separate video on and then at some stage sometime. We're trying to raise a few more funds for
moving into our new area downstairs
We had some fundraising events and someone said why not do a sort of
talking to an agents box that collects a little bit of money and if you put a coin in a
House that's your 2p. That's it
It has no idea what you put in is just a simple coin sensor that's in in in there
It's based on a Raspberry Pi detects a coin going in and just say a random phrase
It's sometimes miss announcements trying to solicit money off visitors particularly Wednesday overnight
But you'll find all sorts of odd things like this around the hack space
This is an old al DSL modem over to see the Raspberry Pi there
It's been fitted into a little amplifier circuit to getting sound there if you press the button on it
Replays the last message depressing enough times it
Okay, so we have all sorts of equipment that people get access to so this is actually a computer-controlled
embroidery machine
So members can do designs at home bring their designing on a memory stick use the software on this computer
To convert into the right formats to do the embroidery on this machine
There's a number of machines that you need to do an induction with us before you can gain access and we record who's done
The training through the RFID access system
So if I put my card in there?
They'll just say not inducted and I won't be able to turn the machine on so I've looked on the training
But if someone else comes in and has done the training they can put the car in here
And turn the machine on it and they can obviously use it
All of this has been made in-house by members against based on an Arduino an RFID car reader and then we've got our laser cut
Box over that area we've got lots of crafts and art materials. Lots of textile materials. That's
Of interest as some members. We also have another group of members who look after these vending machines
So we've now got two vending machines
This particular one is featured in a computer file video before it's all on the same rfid
Saxis system as the machines and the doors. The last time we came that was full of bits of electronics
Yeah
it used to be but we found that the foodstuff sells better and brings a bit more money into the hack space this area we've
Got woodworking tools
So in this area for all of the dusty woodworking tool so we've got a big table saw here
So it was a couple of members over there using the planer fit yourself
So here we've got our laser cutter this is used for cutting acrylic
Plywood MDF they'll also cut paper card leather. It will engrave glass it will engrave slate
We do get a lot of people joining just to get access to this machine because this is not sort of thing you could have
In your garage at home wrong knotless
You've got lots of space and lots of money these cost about six thousand pounds as soon as you powers up
The head will also date them in the corner over there makes quite a lot of noise
The noise is actually the extractor. So the extractors willing to suck all the smoke that's in here out of the way
Okay, so this is the software we use
It works using DXF files just going to quickly import a file
There's a little bit of tidying up when you still on this fart
It comes in as a number of separate points here and then we can send it down to the laser cutter
Once we put the appropriate powers and speeds in and then the laser cutter will cut the part out
So in this area, we've got our metalwork tools. We've got band saws because you metalwork
we have a lathe if anyone's doing metal turning we've got a
Bridgeport mill milling machine and at the back we've got welding equipment. We've got MIG welder and a TIG welder
And over this side here
We've got a ball tomaters hacksaw so you can if you've got your large piece of metal to cut up
There's no need to do it by hands
This is a nice parallel cut you put your metal in here and it's or through and then turned itself off when it's finished
these old railway clocks have come from
The work place of one of our members. So one of them there we've got running with a the time on it
We're not got this one running the moment
So nothing in hack space is currently on two floors and the both ones directly below the other
But unfortunately a bit of a walk around to get between the two levels
But eventually we hope to have enough money to put in our own staircase our own or our own lift even between the two floors
Okay, so this is our new area
And in this area here we've got some more
Computer-controlled equipment, so we've got a computer-controlled
Milling machine here
We had someone just recently making some parts for guitars on here, which looked fantastic
And over the far end we've got a computer-controlled
lathe
In the middle. We got a 3d printer do I get see much use then?
No, the computer-controlled milling machine the computer control
They don't get an awful lot of use and I think the problem with that is that we don't have any
Induction program for those so if you want to use those you got to do a lot of reading up
a lot of self-training perhaps watching YouTube videos
To learn how to draw the parts and then to get them the parts through the tool paths for cutting them out
This computer might be a bit dated, but it's powerful enough to run this blaze
It's all of the lighting in this new area is computer control. We've got arduino. 'he's
Running the show down here
It's all in this control box. And there's actually a web interface you can use to turn on individual lights in this area
I didn't develop this is all done by another member so we can turn on individual lights on and off
So if I just select one in here?
Sure, which one it is? But well the lights will go off if I do that. Yes one over there
anyway, quite a few members in particular like having to go to a web site to
Turn the lights on and off whilst this you know, it's a great use of technology. Some people didn't like that
So we had one member who built a light switch whilst it looks like an ordinary light switch. It's just got a
USB power sly type going into there. We've actually got a pro soon there. I've got an esp8266
One off
We're an opera for perfect organization
If anyone's looking to find the hack space
There's a couple of good websites to take a look at one is wiki dot
hackerspaces dot org where you can find hack spaces all over the world if you're in the UK is
Www.spacetelescope.org transcribed